el precio de la cesta de productos
alimentarios básicos no para de subir el
índice de la organización de las
naciones unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación que sigue la variación
mensual de los precios internacionales
de estos alimentos aumentó un 12.6 por
ciento en marzo una de las tantas
consecuencias de la guerra porque rusia
y ucrania son los principales
exportadores mundiales de materias
primas agrícolas sober sobre el efecto
de the war in crime the first hay varios
efectos de la guerra en ucrania el
primero es lo que está ocurriendo en el
interior y la gente en ucrania que está
perdiendo la seguridad alimentaria y
luego está el efecto en el mundo debido
al aumento de los precios a los niveles
que estamos observando hoy en los
cereales especialmente en el trigo y el
maíz no todavía en el arroz porque en el
arroz tenemos buenos suministros y eso
significa que las personas más pobres
cuyo gasto depende de los alimentos la
mayor parte de su gasto serán las más
afectadas
un aumento de los precios que se suma a
las tensiones sobre la seguridad
alimentaria mundial que ya existían con
los conflictos internos el cambio
climático y la pandemia de ccoo y 19
como telón de fondo en países ya
frágiles de áfrica y medio oriente que
importan directamente materias primas de
ucrania o rusia la población teme lo
peor
cada día de un nuevo aumento de los
precios de los alimentos por ejemplo el
azúcar antes comprábamos una bolsa por
43 dólares pero ahora cuesta 60 dólares
las autoridades tienen que intervenir de
lo contrario corremos el riesgo de morir
de hambre si se frenará de forma
permanente la exportación de alimentos
desde ucrania en rusia la fao advierte
que entre 8 y 13 millones de personas
más podrían sufrir desnutrición en todo
el mundo